is a huge admiration for what he's done
as a leader taken us out of the eu won
the election set the country on a new
path
we have never disagreed in any way about
brexit policy
right up to the last day we've been
absolutely aligned on that and liz trust
and chris head and harris i'm sure are
going to do a great job
i left the government because as i think
is well known i couldn't support certain
policies most recently on covid
restrictions and plan b
and if you're a minister you have to
support collective responsibility you
have support decisions of the government
and i couldn't so that's why i had to
leave
have you given up on the prime minister
do you think he's lost his direction is
it time for him to go in your view this
is absolutely not about leadership this
is about policy differences i'm
absolutely confident this country's got
a great future under boris johnson's
leadership if we can get the policies
right so he's the right man to carry on
i mean it's in a state of chaos and your
departure actually seems to be at a time
when it's going to cause maximum damage
to him
so the departure was intended to be in
the new year and has come out earlier
than we thought the departure is about
policy it's about policy differences and
i'm absolutely confident that he's the
right man to take the country forward
if he pursues these policies including
perhaps further restrictions that might
be coming this week in your view will
more of your cabinet colleagues follow
you out of cabinet by resigning so i
can't speak for anybody else i can only
say what i think which is that i don't
support coercive policies on kovitz the
prime minister's got some very difficult
decisions to take and i'm sure he'll be
thinking very hard of them thanks very
much do you think he's lost touch with
what the voters won
kate's with us um hi kate what do you
make of that well clearly lord frost
absolutely at pains there to say that
this was not about the prime minister of
boris johnson and his authority in
number 10. now the reason for that
is because as you heard there this
resignation was not supposed to come out
until january it has come out at a very
damaging time for boris johnson of
course off the back of a by-election
loss in the midst of lots of questions
about parties that took place in downing
street this morning of course the garden
party in may 2020 we understand from
that photo this could not possibly have
come at a worse time for a really key
ally of boris johnson's not just
somebody who was a heavyweight when it
comes to brexit and european policy but
also a close personal ally and cabinet
for the prime minister so to lose lord
frost at a time like this and
particularly when he's reiterated there
that it's about coercive policies on
covid that is very very problematic
indeed when those conversations about
the data about the potential for next
steps that may or may not be needed
about how fast things are moving here in
westminster the prime minister needs his
cabinet behind him he's got a front page
today suggesting that they are not many
of them want to wait and see and the
scientists saying we absolutely cannot
wait we need to act now it's an
impossible position but the one man who
has to make the decision is the prime
minister and it will be a difficult week
ahead for him